[Music]
recently this is very true 100% true
something was brought to my attention
involving one of our show's graphic
designers pierre bernard there he is
right there yeah that's him yeah and
apparently absolutely true I was told
Pierre has some items in his work area
the graphic design office that are
frankly creeping people out I heard
about it I went around I asked a couple
people they all said no it's absolutely
true it's creeping people out so I took
a camera crew along to investigate
here's what happened
Pierre alright good to see you this is
Pierre Bernard hi Pierre you've been
charged with having odd objects in your
work space how do you plead not guilty
or a normal fellow very normal do you
draw naked women on the weekends yes do
you go to comic-con and try to date much
younger women dressed as super heroines
occasionally okay is this your work
space right here yes all right what's
this woman's Black Canary do you find
her erotic she's one of my favorites yes
why don't you show me the one that you
may favorites the Brazilian girl fire
you're most attracted to this doll
that's on your desk yes
are you ever alone with this doll you're
not no never alone with it you tell me
specifically what about her Anatomy
appeals to you I just like the costume I
don't see much of a costume
how many other sets of these do you have
several you have more of these these are
just the tip of the iceberg I have more
just in case damage occurs or they go
miss him so if one of them became
damaged while you were doing something
to it storage maybe the three more maybe
you have two more you say is that enough
because what it that's what if well they
come three to a pack in there random
cement many of these many okay cuz if
anything happened to this one god forbid
right okay but nothing's going to happen
to her I was long as you're around you
take good care of it won't you I was
okay you nervous yeah no you seen Tiny's
the word insane
does it Angry you and I do this to her
this isn't making you mad Mike right now
okay oh she's whispering something in my
ear you cuz it make you look little
jealous no we're free to talk to whoever
is that angry what do you really feel
there nothing she probably told you a
joke he's told me a million times
[Applause]
basically this is the future and it's a
world where us men are reduced to 5
inches tall people and robots work in
the workspace and replacement of men
okay I can't help but noticing she has a
healthy idea that healthy women can be
in a work space and not be harassed
anymore so that's part of your socially
responsible message yes that this woman
has breasts that seem to be straining
the buttons
why wouldn't she buy it if you looked
even closer you'll notice one is over
her arm it's so big just women wearing a
bra I'm not sure yes she is cuz there's
no nipples are these the largest breasts
that you've ever drawn no I've drawn
Audrey Jean Margaret yes I've had a girl
who's a dancer who posed for me and yes
a lot bigger she's still alive and
dancing would you tell me right now if
you did something to her okay you let
her go just probably got away while you
were talking to your dolls so here you
don't think that other female employees
would be uncomfortable at all with this
none of them actually come in here okay
you think there's a reason why no women
will come in here
have no idea I wonder what it could be I
wonder what it could be you go on
Craigslist a lot don't you
occasionally there's something
worthwhile looking at I should explain
to you why this particular item it says
female mannequin this is a naked woman
very realistic I wanted to see if this
person had other Americans because
there's one in particular that I'm
looking for I saw it in New York
it's of a woman's torso down to her legs
and it's very voluptuous but on it and
the top is cut off flat and I thought it
would make a nice little hat I wanted to
buy a couple of them take them to
electrician and have them run the wires
through it and they could be nice end
tables he kind of you're fired
I'm gonna take your fire do you no
longer work here and you're going to the
hospital when do you say that's too much
those breasts are too big that butts too
voluptuous if a woman needed two golf
carts to drive her breasts in front of
her as she walked I would say that's way
too big right but you'd want to take her
out for coffee yeah I'm gonna come with
you to check this out okay is that
Alright yeah that's fine
[Music]
hi ru Mike hey Mike I'm Conan O'Brien
this is Peter I called you about the
mannequin hey Mike do you have anything
with bigger breasts than this is this
okay or what size breasts you think this
is huh
they look like bees she's okay not to
mention it almost looks like someone's
been handling them too
hand prints there's something on there
what do you mean handling this some
marks under the breasts
yeah okay let me open another one I'm
saying I said this one looks cleaner
this one's cleaner what do you mean no
one's handled this one right there's a
bunch of this you don't want to be with
one that's been with someone else
yeah yeah that's called a face of a
woman that's where they think and talk
with that
my battle I think you're crazy not to
get these they're gonna go into storage
at this why does everything go into
storage because I don't have room
wait you don't even have room for what
we're looking for you keep buying all
this [ __ ] we're gonna have the money to
buy a bigger apartment why don't you buy
the bigger apartment then you can fill
it with all kinds of butts
[Music]
what I'm saying still holds we'll take
all the mannequins hey you made this
perv very very yeah congratulations on
fulfilling your sick needs
[Applause]
he's creepy mannequin lamps
[Applause]